for a trusted budget airline having the
private details of nine million of its
customers hat doesn't exactly inspire
confidence email addresses travel
information and for 2,000 people their
credit card details
easyJet says it was the victim of a
highly sophisticated attack but it's
declined to comment on reports that some
of the tools and techniques used match
that of a group of suspected Chinese
hackers that are believed to be behind
multiple attacks on Airlines cyber
expert David M says only those who are
working on the live investigation itself
will be able to say for certain it's
really too early to tell I think that
will only come up further on once
they've kind of been able to analyze
exactly what the chain of events was in
actual fact if you look back
historically at breaches of this kind
sometimes they can be the result of a
sophisticated targeted attack other
times it can be quite so hot that unist
cyber criminals who managed to get in
easyJet was made aware of the hack back
in January while it says there's no
evidence that any personal information
has been misused on the advice of the
Information Commissioner's Office it's
contacting anyone whose details were
compromised
to warn them to look out for potential
phishing scams everybody's going through
such uncertainty at the moment with
coronavirus people who are booked to go
on holidays but flights for other
reasons a finding that the flights are
canceled so they're desperately trying
to get through to airlines like easyJet
at the moment to get refunds and things
so it's a real prime opportunity for
these horrible scammers to steal
people's deep details and to use them to
trick them in say phishing emails will
use them for other kind of scams
easyJet says it will contact anyone
who's been affected in the next week and
for a security breach on this scale it's
likely to face a fine with planes
grounded and summer getaways cancelled
the budget airline was already
struggling financially and now things
just went from bad to worse Katie
Spencer Sky News